[Music]
in his famous novel the plague albert
camus writes quote we learn in time of
pestilence that there are more things to
admire in men than to despise you could
say that about the coronavirus and the
aids epidemic that started 40 years ago
on this world aids day it's estimated
about 36 million people have died from
hiv-related causes and about 38 million
people are living with the virus and
there is still no cure our chief medical
correspondent dr john lapook reflects on
his own experience working at the height
of the aids crisis he went back to a
place central to that time in his life
in the fall of 1976 i entered medical
school i was eager to make a difference
but when you're a first year medical
student you don't know a whole lot of
medicine
so my contribution to clinical care was
basically limited to bringing my college
singing group to the hospital to
entertain sick children
i graduated in may 1980 and off i went
to start my internship as a newly minted
doctor at what was then called columbia
presbyterian medical center
then in march of 1981 federal health
officials consider it an epidemic yet
you rarely hear a thing about it i saw
my first patient with what would become
known as aids he was suffering from
something i had never seen before
an eye infection from a common virus
that a normal immune system could
usually handle but his immune system was
anything but normal
[Music]
he died
and for years so did every single
patient with aids who i helped care for
so many of them were in what should have
been the prime of their lives
they all had so-called opportunistic
infections that attacked people with
weakened immune systems hiv the virus
that causes aids
would not be discovered for another two
years
but we were all discovering first hand
that it could decimate the immune system
we're all scared to death we'd like to
know what the hell we're supposed to do
here what should we do should we stay
home and lock ourselves back in the
closet or you know what should we do we
don't know what we're dealing with and
it's deadly and it's transmissible
wow and it was right here in this very
amphitheater
where students and staff got together
for what was called grand rounds trying
to figure out what in the world was
going on
we all felt helpless
and i certainly didn't think i was
making a difference
i'm 31 years old
and i've watched
a great many of my friends die sometimes
patients would get better for a while if
their infections were treatable but they
would always get readmitted to the
hospital i remember one man especially
well a car mechanic in washington
heights
a husband and a father
a lovely guy who could not have been
more grateful for the care we gave him
even though our care didn't prevent his
death
we want to live
that is all we want america then in 1987
for the first time a drug to treat aids
patients got final government approval
today the drug azt is not a vaccine
against the disease nor a cure it was
astonishing
finally some hope
and thanks to scientific research the
treatment gradually improved over the
years and hiv aids became a more chronic
though often still devastating condition
[Music]
over the next 30 years images of those
brutal early days remained with me
but they mostly stayed in the background
then ten years ago i saw the normal
heart
a gut-wrenching play about the early
days of the epidemic
at the end the names of people who had
died of aids were projected on the walls
of the theater
i couldn't move my eyes filled with
tears
as the sadness of that time came
flooding back
those memories were a big reason why in
april of 2020 i helped out on the covet
wards at nyu langone health where i'm a
professor of medicine i wanted to share
what i had learned with the young
students doctors and nurses who might be
feeling as helpless as i did in 1981.
they were way ahead of me they had
already arranged for their patients who
were in isolation to video chat with
loved ones
or kept them company by sitting at the
bedside they understood the therapeutic
value
of human touch
of reaching out and holding a hand
they also seem to understand it was okay
to shed a tear or two and it was okay to
take advantage of mental health services
over the years i've learned there are
all sorts of ways to make a difference
and it's almost never something as
dramatic as saving somebody's life
much more often it's by making their
journey gentler
by showing them compassion and empathy
by listening
by being present
bravo john lepouk i'm telling you you
know he is
to me one of the most empathetic caring
people that i've that i've ever met so
it's no surprise to see early in his
career that he was still that same
person yeah his message is so important
and so true especially on this world
aids day which was essentially created
to unite everybody around the world to
try and fight this deadly disease and to
bring empathy to it my mom's brother
uncle ricky passed away from aids
in 1990 i was nine years old
um
that forced us to become familiar with
aids yes and that familiarity turned
into education yep so that piece was
remember in the beginning we were so
afraid nobody knew what we were dealing
with oh thank you john it was tough back
then because no one knew what it was no
one knew what it was